JOANNA SMITH: Good afternoon,
everybody, and welcome to this
week's episode of Google+
Developers Live, where I'm
going to take some
time to discuss
our developer policies.
And the reason that I wanted to
do this episode is because
I wanted to be able to make it
comprehensible, to define the
key points and break it down
in a way that's easy to
understand.
I also want to emphasize that
these policies are designed to
ensure that there's a consistent
user experience.
We want our users to know that
when they click on something
that has the Google name or the
Google+ name on it, they
understand what's going
to happen next.
And the other thing that is an
advantage of this episode is
that the approach here is that
these are the things that we
look at when you apply
for additional quota.
So if you want a higher rate
limit on some of the calls you
make, you need to make sure
you're already compliant with
some of these tips and tricks.
And that'll make sure that
you go a lot faster.
Not being up to date with this
is going to slow down your
process and make your request
take longer to get through.
So keep that in mind as you go
through and listen to the rest
of this episode.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to start with our
developer policy.
And this you can find
at developers.googl
e.com/plus/policies.
And I'm going to just pull
out a few things here.
There's really a lot
to look at here.
But I recommend you go ahead
and take the time to read
through it.
It should only take 10 to
15 minutes to skim.
And it will help you keep in
mind the most important things
that you need to know when
you're designing an app that
uses Google+ in any way.
But first, let's take a look at
Section c.2.a, because this
is one of the most important
things to keep in mind, when
you need to follow the
basic guideline.
The basic tip to our
policies is never
let the user be surprised.
And so the thing that hits this
point the best is 2.a.
And it says, don't mislead your
users about what your
application does or trick
them into using it.
And this sounds really harsh.
But it's actually not as
harsh as it may seem.
Because what it really does,
what it really emphasizes, is
that your user needs to know
what's going to happen when
they click on something with
the Google name on it.
So for example, if I click on
the Google+ Sign In button,
and I don't get signed in,
I'm suddenly confused.
The best use case that I can
think of is if I click on the
Google+ Sign In button, and I
suddenly have a handful of
celery and vegetables.
Lots of vegetables.
I don't want to click on the
Sign In button and get
attacked by vegetables.
I want to click on the Sign In
button and know that I'm a
part of your app, and know
that there's my name, my
information, that's going to
make a better user experience
for myself.
So keep that in mind.
The other thing that I want to
point on that hits on this
"don't surprise your users"
is Section b.1.c.
And what this means is
don't use stale data.
You don't want your user to
have data that's not been
updated in a while.
You want to make sure that if
they delete something on
Google+, it's not still on
your site a week later.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Where's
my celery!
JOANNA SMITH: So the best way
you can do this is update your
cache regularly.
Make sure that you don't keep
any data forever, because that
wouldn't be a very good
user experience.
But also make sure that
everything in there gets
refreshed on a regular basis.
So like I said, there's
a lot here.
But it's definitely worth
going through.
But the easiest way to make
sure you're abiding by
developer policies is that
simple rule of never let the
user be surprised.
Because if you're meeting that
in every possible way, you're
probably meeting the rest
of our policies.
So the other major thing that
I wanted to hit on today are
our branding guidelines.
And these can be found
at developers.googl
e.com/plus/branding-guidelines.
And there's kind
of a lot here.
We have some helpful
links at the top.
But then what we have are our
buttons, our standard options,
the things that just
come for free.
And you can actually download.
And a lot of people haven't
noticed this, but we have a
download link over here
to the right.
And this has all of our
attributes, all of our buttons
that you might need for your
app to sign in, to share.
They're easy to find, and
they're right here.
There are several options,
of course.
We've talked about
those before.
But let's move on to the
other important things.
This next section is what
we refer to as the equal
prominence specification.
And what this means is that we
want all of your sign in
options to be clear and equal.
If you are offering Google+ Sign
In, it should be as up
front and as discoverable as
any other authentication
service that you have.
And they should all be
there for the user
to have a real choice.
And that's really
important to us.
The other thing that's really
cool about this section is
that it points out an exception
that you might want
to be aware of.
If you're designing a custom
button, we have a lot of
specifications and parameters
for you.
But if you're doing something
in your design that doesn't
quite fit one of those, and yet
you're doing it across all
of the authentication services
that you provide, we'll abide
by the exception as well.
Because it's consistent in the
look and feel of your design.
It's part of your site, and
we understand that.
So this is really
cool for you.
Now, let's take a look at some
of the custom button design
specifications.
There's kind of a lot here,
and I understand that.
So I was going to just pull out
the key points for you,
and you can take a look later
if you want to get to know
more about it.
So the first, with regard to
size, is that we just want you
to preserve the original
aspect ratio.
Don't really care how large or
how small the button is, so
long as it's the same ratio.
With text, this is where it
kind of gets important.
You want to choose the wording
very carefully.
Do something like "Sign in with
Google." It needs to be
very clear to the user that
they're not signing in to
Google with your site, but
rather they're using their
Google identity to authenticate
your app, to gain
access to other features.
That's the distinction.
And your button text
needs to show that.
In any case, though, never say
Google+ on the button.
It needs to be apparent to the
user that signing in with
Google grants access to more
than just their Google+ data.
A developer can add a scope, for
example, to gain access to
other services, like
Google Drive.
And that's beyond the
scope of Google+.
And the user should not be
confused or surprised to see
if they're giving access
to Google Drive, using
Google+ Sign In.
So only ever use the word Google
on your button, just to
keep it clear.
Also, for color, we have some
specific shades of red and
white listed.
And we'd like you to use
these if you're going
to use red and white.
We don't want some off-shade
or slightly
wrong look and feel.
This ratio is kind of
important to us.
The font that we chose
is Roboto Bold.
This is a True Type font,
and we have to download
instructions for you.
And then finally, padding.
This is one of those
bits that's of
hard to decide sometimes.
So what we would look like is
we'd like the right and left
sides of the text to
be the same width
as the Google+ icon.
It's that simple.
So you can just use the same
width over and over.
We have a section dedicated to
the Google+ icon by itself.
And then we have some "where you
shouldn't go" directions.
And the most important thing
here is that you don't use
anything that's old
or outdated.
You may have designed your app
over a year and a half ago,
but Google+ has evolved a lot
since then, and we would like
it if you would update your
branding to meet our
guidelines.
And like I said, this is one of
those things that I'm going
to check for, for any quota
request that comes by my desk.
And if you haven't met that,
if you are using an old
button, that's an immediate
hesitation.
You have to fix that before we
can approve your request.
So the more up-to-date you are,
the sooner you can get
through our process for
additional rate limits.
So, the last thing I want
to talk about, as far as
branding, is I have an
example for you.
And this is one of my favorite
partners that we have.
This is Fancy.
And they are a pretty cool site
for how to buy things or
really interesting products
they have a lot of.
But what they did
here is awesome.
They built a custom button, but
it fits seamlessly into
their design, which
is why it's such
a good custom button.
They've preserved our original
red and white contrast.
We really like that.
They've got the Google there.
But what they did that's
so cool is they
redesigned our button.
Our button was rounded, a
little bit more shaded.
They wanted a flatter look,
because you'll notice that
their entire site has
a pretty flat look.
It's consistent.
So they have equal prominence.
They have the right colors.
They have the right text.
And they made it fit seamlessly
into the entire
design of their side.
This is an example
of a well done
customized sign in button.
And you can actually turn to
Fancy for a lot of other
ideas, because their
implementation is pretty cool
all around.
So I encourage you to check
out their site if you're
looking for inspiration.
So that's everything that I
have for you regarding our
policies and our branding
guidelines.
But before we go, I wanted to
take a moment, because I've
noticed a lot of questions
lately in the Google+
Developers community regarding
some of these developer notice
emails that have gone out.
And these are a sort of
implementation check up.
And they're actually intended
to help developers find and
fix their implementation.
So, the most obvious causes of
these emails are some of the
things that I talked
about today.
And for that reason, I really
hope that this can help you
find where you might have gone
wrong, if you're one of those
developers that's wondering
what triggered this email.
These are some of the things
that you want to look at.
So I hope that's helped
you all today.
And if you have any questions,
feel free to ask them in the
comments of this event or raise
them in the community.
And I'll take a look
this week.
Thanks everybody, and have
a good afternoon.